こんばんは
一市長へ
[音楽]
誰が t シャツと同じ神レア
バカにしとんのか皆さんは
自意識というもの
信じますでしょうか世の中にはいろんな景色があります
中には
危険な例をた度この現世に高齢させるという実験の儀式もあります
僕は昔ひとりかくれんぼという
危険の儀式をやろうとしたんですけど一緒にやろうとしていた孝愛が急に泣き出して
救助
中段になったという過去がございますそれ以来儀式みたいなことはやめようと思ったん
ですけど
まあ夏なんで
別にいいじゃねぇ
wii
みたいな感じでちょっと別のやつをやってみようかなと思っております
これは僕はあんまり聞いたことなかったんですけど謎のアハーンと名前がない謎の
ツイッターからとかな寄せられた儀式でございます
読ませていただきます絶対にやってはいけない恐怖の儀式太郎君と花子さんをやって
ほしいです少しひとりかくれんぼと似ているかも
1紙で人形を3体作るうち2つを赤と青で塗る青が太郎
赤が花子さ
ひとつは自分の身代わりとして爪や髪の毛を派
[音楽]
賑やかですね
に花子さんを兵の市民にを切ったろーくんを別の部屋に話しておきます
その時太郎君の体の一部を
派の子さんのそばに置いておく花牡丹の大好きになったろうくん
僕が殺しましたにくいですか今から20分間
僕は部屋のどこかに隠れますもし見つけられなければ僕の勝ちですと海上宣言宣言後
自分の身代わりを好きな所に置く
こうワートリハダのもやませんで次に隠れます20分3つ
からなかった場合花子さんの元へ行き北はじめの価値体の3回言う
そして3大の人形バラバラにやブック以上が二色になります
おまけみたいになってるんですけども最後に自分人形はお焚き上げをしてください
きています
各論夏休みな今回は
この
怪しい儀式
涼平くん5部屋でやらせていただきますじゃあ今非常にしてました
僕の家めっちゃ一人ですよ人が居すぎてちょっと降霊術がうまくいかなそうだったんで
橋脚の部屋でやっぱここは名鑑ない組なんで
たくないんですよとねー back a は米20分間
なんかやっぱりなければいいですこの母さんん
ちゃいけないやつなんじゃないですかこれいやサコは会で狙って由布
妻にやっていきます
[音楽]
入って受けて紙で人形3体を作りました
これはそれぞれ太郎くん派の子さん
僕の身代わりという感じで3体準備していきます
[音楽]
また母ちゃんに置かれるんだろう
というわけで太郎君の花ことを塗っていきました
自分の身代わりとして僕の爪や髪の毛を貼りますうわぁ
2この2件で今度にプリジェルヌケねえよ髪の毛よ
はい
というわけで
ここはないですか花子さんをエアの隅に大きい
太郎君を別の部屋に話しておきますその時
太郎君の体の一部を花子さんのそばに置いておくたら区の左明日切らせていただきます
それぞれ持ち場所に置いていきましょうなんかさんと太郎口のついた部分を提案隅っこ
に置きます
から個別に話を聞くというふうに思います
いただけますはいっ
見て
やっぱとなる波ご飯するですよ本当に声
いきます花子さんの大好きな
太郎君は
僕がこぼすました
にくいですか
今から20分間
僕は部屋のどこかに隠れます
もし見つけられなければ
僕の勝ちです
返してしまいましたこれでも始まっています
なんか身代わりを好きなとかに置いていらしいです9日せていただきますここの
身代わりに10分河口からはじまるので
隠れ場所っ子しかないっしょにもないっす
なんてここで20分間待ちます
時はなことがないですね
かんな
やばいでしょ
止まっていません
ないとっ
ん
かと思います
んでまたでまたございました
ずっとや都内じゃ絶対楽しく1 p まぁスティックなぁには動くよ檜山世界史
ネタと見て本だけじゃないですよ
ナチュラル者だっん
んとっ
はぁんっ
ドックランありました
n ame
やって感じ数してございますはっはっは
あって
をやってる我々どんな子ですかあの勝利はかたんですけど
儀式をさと大汗ない動力ないんで花子さんの元へ行きましょう
買った菅根欠かせためね本チャンカンで
の買ったんで入ってますよ
[音楽]
北
はじめのか着い北はじめの飢え
北はじめのカツ
前回10
[音楽]
大処分ます
展開していましたん
最後にこれはばらばらにやるって終わりということでございます
ここで女だなぁ
でも
勝負には勝ったのでまた次回もあぶない儀式を400に入れ
やってゆく
[音楽]
me
ni
あっはぁ